[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und marietta slomka
guten abend das robert koch institut
meldet heute knapp 100 27.000 neue
infektionen wie hoch die dunkelziffer
ist lässt sich aktuell schwer sagen
demnächst lässt sich das vermutlich noch
weniger sagen wenn weniger infizierte
durch pcr tests erkannt werden die
inzidenz steigt jedenfalls weiter rasant
und es gibt auch weiter tote 214 meldet
das rk ii für die letzten 24 stunden vor
diesem hintergrund setzt die politik
weiter aufs impfen dazu rufen alle
bundestagsparteien auf außer der afd
aber nicht alle impfbefürworter sind
deshalb auch für eine impfpflicht
morgen würde starts im parlament die
erste große debatte geben weniger
berichtet die einen in diesem parlament
quälen sich mit den vielen fragen und
folgen die an einer impfpflicht hängen
andere sind schon immer dagegen fdp mann
wolfgang kubicki wird wie viele aus der
afg und linksfraktion nein sagen so viel
ist schon klar
zunächst einmal entspricht nicht meinem
menschenbild menschen zu verpflichten zu
etwas was sie nicht wollen ich habe das
recht mich zu entscheiden was ich getan
habe mich impfen zu lassen und zwar
menschen das recht sich zu entscheiden
dass sie sich nicht impfen lassen so
hatte es die fdp im wahlkampf einst
versprochen andere bedrückt die impf
lücke und die pandemie lage mehr aus der
fdp und von den grünen gibt es deshalb
den vorschlag für ein verpflichtendes
beratungsgespräch um skeptiker zu
erreichen und eine impfpflicht für alle
über 50
hier ist geht es sich um
ungerechtigkeiten sondern medizinische
tatsachen dass ab dem alter von 50
jahren natürlich die menschen besonders
betroffen sind wenn sie keinen
impfschutz haben und das müssen wir
natürlich bekämpfen denn am ende des
tages ist das ziel sehr klar wir wollen
das krankenhaus vor überforderung
schützen ein dritter gruppenantrag aus
der ampel eine impfpflicht für alle ab
18 jahren inklusive bußgelder und
maximal drei impfungen
wir wollen gleichzeitig eine befristete
regelung weil es auch sein kann dass
irgendwann aufgrund einer hohen
grundimmunisierung die impfung nicht
mehr erforderlich ist das ist was wir
vorschlagen das wollen wir auf den weg
bringen das ganze bußgeld bewehrt machen
und von daher einfach strukturiert
nachvollziehbar um letztendlich einen
hohen schutz der bevölkerung zu
erreichen den bundeskanzler vorführen
weil er keine mehrheit in der ampel hat
das versucht die union sie geht ohne
eigenen antrag in diese debatte obwohl
die unions-ministerpräsidenten für die
impfpflicht sind es ist eine der größten
politischen entscheidungen im jahr 2022
die durch den bundeskanzler durch den
bundesgesundheitsminister sogar
pointiert ab november nach vorne
getrieben worden deswegen erwarten wir
von der ampel das den gesetzesvorschlag
macht eigentlich von der regierung nun
kommt es nicht von den regierungen nun
kommt von den abgeordneten der ampel und
da schauen wir uns ganz genau an und
dass die cdu csu fraktion jetzt
irgendwie ohne haltung unterwegs ist man
weiß nicht mal so richtig was sie wollen
wie sie auch in die rede morgen
einsteigen wollen sie wollen sich nicht
an die üblichen absprachen halten das
irritiert schon sehr und ist vielleicht
der neuen rolle in der opposition
geschultert geschuldet in der man sich
noch zurechtfinden muss es geht wie
immer nicht nur um inhalte es geht auch
ums profilieren auch innerhalb der
regierungskoalition bei dieser frage ist
mir die innere verfasstheit des
bundeskanzlers relativ egal genauso wie
ihm ja meine inneren verfasstheit egal
ist sonst hätte er sich hingestellt und
erklärt er sei für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht und mache dass ich es auch
zu einer frage des politischen
überlebens das halte ich für unklug in
berlin nennt man die impfpflicht eine
gewissensentscheidung was in den
nächsten wochen zu beweisen wäre
in der debatte morgen wird das
jedenfalls noch deutlicher werden wie
komplex das thema ist da geht es auch
nicht nur um das ob sondern auch um das
wie und um grundsätzliche juristische
fragen laura bahn die kunst christian
rufus haben sich dieser debatte
angenommen und einmal stellvertretend
für befürworter und kritiker die
wichtigsten verfassungsrechtlichen pro
und contra argumente zusammen gesteckt
die allgemeine impfpflicht auch unter
juristen umstritten und vor allem für
kritiker eine maßnahme die zumindest
momentan zu weit geht
das grundrecht auf unverletzlichkeit
auf unversehrtheit der körperlichen
integrität
beinhaltet eben das recht eines jeden
menschen zu
bestimmen ob er sich einer therapie oder
als sonst ihren mit tierischen maßnahmen
unterziehen würde aber steht der schutz
des lebens anderer nach über zwei jahren
pandemie nicht über dem recht auf
körperliche unversehrtheit
wenn der staat gute allgemeinwohl kunde
hat dann kann er in die körperliche
unversehrtheit einzelne eingreifen zb
durch eine impfpflicht und der schutz
von leben und gesundheit vieler gegen
die plötzlich geringfügige körperliche
beeinträchtigung durch die impfung ist
definitiv ein solcher guter grund und
dennoch sind die intensivstationen
gerade nicht überfüllt die todeszahlen
niedrig die impfung bietet keinen
hundertprozentigen schutz wäre eine
impfpflicht also noch verhältnismäßig
es kommt sehr darauf an was die
zwecksetzung einer impfpflicht ist
begründet man jetzt diese impfpflicht
was ich für richtig halte mit dem
maximalen immunisierung grad der
bevölkerung damit wir endlich aus dieser
pandemie rauskommen dann ist es
ausreichend dass impfstoffe auch gegen
neue varianten ein schutz mehrwert
irgendeine wirksamkeit aufweist das ist
der fall mit einer impfpflicht wird die
pandemie dennoch nicht sofort enden
geimpfte können sich trotzdem anstecken
das virus wenn auch seltener weitergeben
und wie sich omikron entwickelt ist auch
noch nicht ganz klar und deshalb müsste
man meines erachtens noch eine
fundiertere datenbasis haben um
beurteilen zu können ob es im herbst zum
beispiel noch notwendig ist eine solche
allgemeine impfpflicht
durchzusetzen die kernfrage ist deshalb
gibt es noch mildere mittel bei gleicher
wirksamkeit
eine impfpflicht für ältere menschen
etwa eine alternative
[Musik]
ein milderes mittel das würde ich dann
wenn man schon diesen sehr kühnen sprung
wagt in eine in den übergang in eine
allgemeine impfpflicht wenn man das auf
diese
risikogruppen geschenkt man muss
wirklich genau schauen es geht um
mildere mittel die gleich wirksam sind
das ist der verfassungsrechtliche test
und die einfache antwort hier ist doch
letztlich keiner kann für die denkbaren
mildern mittel die in betracht kommen
sicher garantieren dass die gleiche
wirksamkeit bestätigt
ich gibt es gute gründe für und gegen
eine impfpflicht das ob und wie
diskutiert ab morgen das parlament
wenn irgendjemand von uns die hand hebt
um mit der afg zusammenzuarbeiten
dann steht am nächsten tag an
parteiausschlussverfahren an also hat
das friedrich merz im dezember in einem
interview mit dem spiegel angekündigt
die derart mag ich gezogene brandmauer
muss dann aber natürlich auch stehen was
im einzelfall ziemlich schwierig sein
kann denn für alle politischen parteien
gilt unliebsamen mitglieder loszuwerden
kann mühsam werden einfach mal schnell
raus schmeißen geht nicht max otte
allerdings vorsitzender der so genannten
werte union bzw
was davon noch übrig ist macht es der
cdu da aber nun möglicherweise etwas
leichter als andere gewichtigere
kandidaten sagen hier putzen berichtet
rechts sein ist nicht metrisch man kann
max otte also nicht zentimetergenau
verorten den politischen spektrum aber
man kann sich annähern per vergleich der
innerhalb der afg als ziemlich rechts
geltende co-chef kino kubala etwa findet
otto gut herr professor otte ist ein
honoriger politiker wir geben damit
allen wahldelegierten die möglichkeit
ein mann aus der mitte auch an diesem 13
februar zu wählen und deswegen freue ich
mich und möchte mich recht herzlich
bedanken professor max otte bosnier zur
afg ist lange bekannt zwei 18 mal mit
vielen partei vorderen beim sogenannten
neuen hambacher fest etwa mit j morton
dem noch co-chef der mfg spektrum als
gemäßigt gilt ist orte inzwischen
allerdings auch zu recht nach der
ermordung des cdu-politikers weiter
lübke etwa hatte der von hetze gegen
rechte gesprochen ich halte die
nominierung von max otte inhaltlich für
falsch und strategisch für unklug zum
leuten gegenüber dem zdf max otte steht
mit seinen positionen mitnichten in der
mitte der afd
viele in berlin sehen in der nominierung
nur eine weitere provokation ein
weiteres schauspiel nun auf als
politischer bühne zumal die nominierung
eben auch intern umstritten war
auch hier kandidaten richtige
provokation an es ist mir ernst ich habe
ihn von meiner kindheit erzählt ich bin
einander dialog kultur aufgewachsen ich
sehe es als möglichkeit wenn sich die
hysterie gelegt hat gräben zuzuschütten
gräben zu begradigen den dialog zu
stärken all dies bliebe wohl eine
fußnote wäre otte mitglied der afd er
ist aber mitglied der cdu und chef der
so genannten werte union vielleicht ist
es die äußerung von deren einstige ikone
die am meisten aussagt über hottes
verortung hans-georg maßen der wiederum
im cdu kosmos als radikal rechts gilt
befand durch ottes nominierung werde die
arbeit der werte union die innerhalb der
cdu wirken soll diskreditiert ich
empfinde es als verrat an den
mitgliedern er trete daher aus der wert
union aus dies also die gemengelage
heute für die cdu ein gewinnerthema weil
die bundespräsidentenwahl für sie schon
zuvor nicht eine eigene kandidatur bekam
man nicht zustande nun also auch noch
otte am mittag gab es eine warnung in
dessen richtung als er die ignorierte am
abend den beschluss
parteiausschlussverfahren plus
sofortiger in zug der mitgliedsrechte
dr max otte hat damit nicht nur die
beschlusslage der union zur angestrebten
wiederwahl von frank walter steinmeier
missachtet er hat insbesondere gegen den
grundsatz der cdu verstoßen in keiner
weise mit der afd zusammenzuarbeiten der
amtsinhaber war übrigens zeitgleich zur
ortes vorstellung auch im reichstag nur
wenige meter entfernt zu gast bei der
fdp an seiner wiederwahl gibt es kaum
zweifel
nach heute wohl weniger denn je
unser gause macht jetzt erstmal weiter
mit den nachrichten der europäische
gerichtshof für menschenrechte hat die
türkei wegen der inhaftierung des
deutsch türkischen journalisten der
national verurteilt ankara ankara soll
13.300 euro entschädigung an den
korrespondenten der zeitung die welt
zahlen wegen angeblicher terror
propaganda war hügel 2017/18 in der
türkei ein jahr lang inhaftiert ohne
anklageschrift damit seien seine
menschenrechte auf freiheit und
sicherheit sowie auf freie
meinungsäusserung verletzt worden so das
urteil das aber noch nicht
rechtskräftig ist
deniz yücel begrüßte das urteil kündigte
aber in einem zdf-interview widerspruch
in einem punkt an zu sehen im
heute-journal update später um 0.05 oder
jetzt schon auf zdf heute
der durch das missbrauchs gutachten im
erzbistum münchen und freising belastete
kardinal wetter hat einen großteil der
vorwürfe gegen ihn zurückgewiesen
von den 21 fällen in denen er sich
falsch verhalten haben soll erkannte der
heute 93 jährige nur einen als
zutreffend an es sei objektiv falsch
gewesen einen wegen sexuellen
missbrauchs rechtskräftig verurteilten
priester in eine andere gemeinde zu
schicken das erfülle ihn mit scham sagte
kardinal wetter er bitte um
entschuldigung
nach dem amoklauf an der universität
heidelberg ist das motiv immer noch
unklar die polizei hat eine 32 köpfige
ermittlergruppe eingerichtet
diese geht auch der frage nach wie der
täter an die beiden gewehre und die
munition kommen konnte ein 18-jähriger
biologie student hatte gestern in einem
hörsaal der heidelberger uni um sich
geschossen eine 23-jährige starb durch
einen kopfschuss
drei weitere studierende wurden verletzt
der täter hatte sich im anschluss selbst
getötet der inhaftierte kreml-kritiker
alexej nawalny wird in russland nun
offiziell als terrorist und extremist
geführt er und mehrere seiner
mitstreiter wurden auf eine liste der
russischen
finanzaufsichtsbehörde gesetzt auf der
auch anhänger der terrorgruppe es stehen
navalny ist derzeit in einem straflager
östlich von moskau inhaftiert der 45
jährige gilt als einer der wichtigsten
widersacher des russischen präsidenten
putin
über putin und dessen absichten in der
ukraine berieten sich heute olaf scholz
und emanuel markierung der französische
präsident war zu besuch in berlin man
kündigte an dass sie am freitag mit
wladimir putin telefonieren werde
außerdem wiederholten die beiden was
bereits nach den transatlantischen
beratungen gestern gesagt wurde sollte
russland die ukraine attackieren werde
es dafür einen hohen preis zahlen
doch wie hoch kann dieser preis sein die
gaspipeline nord stream zwei zu stoppen
wäre für putin zweifellos anschlag in
der spd von kanzler olaf scholz gibt es
dagegen aber große vorbehalte auch aus
angst dass sich deutschland damit selbst
schadet ulrike rödl ist der frage
nachgegangen wie abhängig deutschland
von russischem gas ist
[Musik]
die frage ob deutschland abhängig ist
von gasimporten lässt sich mit ja
beantworten unser haupt gaslieferant ist
russland gefolgt von norwegen und den
niederlanden
aus russland importiert deutschland etwa
55 prozent seines gasbedarfs das macht
im deutschen energiemix einen anteil von
etwa 12 prozent aus lieferant ist der
russische staatskonzern gazprom der
präsident putin untersteht er kann
letztlich bestimmen wie viel gas in
deutschen haushalten ankommt aus
norwegen bekommen wir etwa 30 prozent
mehr sagt norwegen ist nicht möglich
weil es nicht mehr produzieren kann die
niederlande decken etwa zehn prozent
unserer gasimporte ab tendenz rückläufig
deutschland kann aus eigener kraft
lediglich etwa fünf prozent seines
gasverbrauchs decken zwar gibt es
hierzulande gasspeicher doch die sind
derzeit gerade mal zur hälfte gefüllt
das reicht für diesen winter länger
nicht sollte also russland seine
gaslieferungen als machtinstrument
nutzen braucht deutschland alternativen
die usa könnten einspringen sie sind
neben katar einer der größten flüssiggas
exporteure allerdings gilt es als so
genanntes schmutziges gas wegen der
umstrittenen fracking methode außerdem
ist es teurer und deutschland bräuchte
mehr terminals putin hat erst kürzlich
zugesichert gaslieferungen nach europa
nicht zu stoppen doch es ist fraglich ob
er sich daran halten wird allerdings
russland ist abhängig von seinen
gasexporten putin wurde sich
wirtschaftlich also selbst schauen und
deutschland würde in diesem winter zwar
nicht frieren doch den preis würden wir
zahlen wirklich gemeint
andere europäer sehen sich dadurch
jedenfalls in ihren warnungen bestätigt
dass man sich von russischem gas besser
nicht abhängig machen sollte für noch
mehr missstimmung sorgt denn der nato
das deutsche nein zu waffenlieferungen
an die ukraine das bleibt andere nato
staaten überlassen
mehrere länder darunter die usa und
großbritannien schicken bereits
ausrüstung munition oder
panzerabwehrwaffen zugleich verstärkt
die nato nun ihre eigenen truppen in
osteuropa so zeigt sich immerhin eines
in dieser krise totgesagte leben länger
nichts wirkt so belebend wie eine
gemeinsame empfundene bedrohung die nato
wirkt plötzlich wieder aktiver und
attraktiver
berichtet florian neumann
man kann ihm kaum entkommen dieser tag
der nato-generalsekretär sendet wo es
nur geht mit stets derselben botschaft
jede aggression gegen die ukraine hätte
schwere konsequenzen russland müsste
einen hohen preis zahlen
die nato mehrfach schon tot gesagt er
lebt sie in dieser krise einen neuen
frühling ohne die nato werden wir jetzt
in einer ziemlich üblen nagel das ist
nur gut geölte maschinerie
und das macht es
viel leichter für uns gemeinsam
drogen zu beurteilen und dann über
angemessene abschreckung zu reden und
die dann auch bereit zu stellen noch im
sommer war die nato an der allianz auf
sinnsuche zermürbt von vier quälend
langen jahren gezeichnet vom desaster
des abzugs aus afghanistan und
beschäftigt mit der frage womit sich das
bündnis beschäftigen sollte es ist
wladimir putin der diese frage vorläufig
beantwortet die bedrohungen im osten
lässt die allianz zusammenrücken und
belebt alte debatten neu zwischen
kollektiver sicherheit und linker oder
russischer nato kritik
offensichtlich handelt es sich ja nicht
um ein verteidigungsbündnis sondern ein
militärbündnis das vor allem dazu dient
bestimmte interessen durchzusetzen und
auch ökonomischer einflusssphären zu
sichern die nato ist für alle ihre
mitglieder und die gesellschaften ihrer
mitglieder die rückversicherung die
lebensversicherung und hat dafür gesorgt
dass wir in europa 70 jahre frieden
stabilität und damit wohlstand hat als
jene die wie ex botschafter erdmann die
nato von innen kennen sagen das bündnis
ist für europa vor allem die chance sich
politisch abzustimmen mit militär
mächten die nicht in der eu sind
großbritannien kanada den usa und so
wirkt die neue krise wie ein booster für
die alte allianz was dabei womöglich auf
der strecke bleibt die strategische
autonomie der eu über die russische
diplomaten in interviews genüsslich
spotten
die eu hat doch selber erklärt dass sie
an den verhandlungen durch die
konsultation mit den usa teilnimmt
also wenn das die strategische autonomie
ist von der die eu selber spricht dann
macht das doch einen ich würde sagen
eher merkwürdigen eindruck
was europäer derzeit kaum ansicht sie
wissen für wirtschaftliche sanktionen
braucht es die eu für echte verteidigung
in der krise aber die nato
und jetzt nochmal gundela zunächst eine
interessante personalie jetzt ist es
offiziell die frühere spd parteichefin
und bundesarbeitsministerin andrea
nahles soll neue vorsitzende der
bundesagentur für arbeit werden darauf
haben sich arbeitgeber verbände und
gewerkschaften verständigt die
bundesregierung muss noch zustimmen dann
kann die 51 jährige im sommer die
nachfolge von detlef scheele antreten
die stimmung an den finanzmärkten ist
etwas nervös zwischen pandemie dem
ukraine konflikt und der nahenden
zinserhöhung in den usa positiv kam da
heute die nachricht an dass der ifo
geschäftsklima index erstmals seit
monaten wieder gestiegen ist valerie die
zuversicht in den unternehmen scheint
also wieder zuzunehmen ja die wirtschaft
scheint langsam einen haken an corona zu
machen zumindest mittelfristig sieht sie
licht am ende des tunnels der optimismus
zieht sich durch viele branchen
besonders gut aber ist die stimmung in
der industrie die auftragsbücher sind
gut gefüllt vor allem aber kann das
verarbeitende gewerbe liefern denn die
lieferengpässe die die produktion
gebremst haben lassen langsam nach etwas
positiver auch der einzelhandel weil
nach lieferstopp wieder mehr ware in den
regalen liegt und die tourismusbranche
ist hoffnungsvoller denn die buchungen
für den sommer ziehen an von einer
trendwende will das ifo institut noch
nicht sprechen aber immerhin von einem
jahresstart mit hoffnungsschimmer die
wirtschaft setzt auf den sommer die
börse schaut nicht so weit in die
zukunft der dax heute wankelmütig
zwischen hoch und tief am ende schafft
er doch noch ein plus die nerven an der
börse sind angespannt das liegt daran
dass in den usa morgen vermutlich eine
zinserhöhung angekündigt wird eine
zeitenwende für den aktienmarkt der seit
jahren vom billigen geld profitiert hat
und immer weiter in die höhe getragen
wurde auch die ukraine krise
verunsichert anleger die zeiten an der
börse werden gerade ruppiger valerie
haller vielen dank zur handball em und
einem versöhnlichen abschluss für die
deutsche nationalmannschaft das dhb team
bezwang im letzten hauptrundenspiel in
einem echten krimi russland ganz knapp
mit 30 29
zum matchwinner avancierte patrick
zieker mit seinem treffer sekunden vor
dem ende schon vor der partie stand das
turnier aus für deutschland allerdings
schon fest die mannschaft von trainer
gislason hatte während der em insgesamt
15 kroner fälle zu beklagen
ski rennläufer linus straße hat den
letzten weltcup slalom vor den
olympischen spielen gewonnen der
münchner fuhr im flutlichtrennen von
schladming vor 1000 begeisterten
zuschauern von platz fünf im ersten lauf
noch zu seinem dritten sieg im weltcup
weite teile der türkei und griechenlands
erleben eine massive kaltfront und
außergewöhnliche schneestürme die
räumarbeiten laufen aber eis und schnee
lehman den regulären betrieb wie hier am
flughafen istanbul weiterhin fallen
zahlreiche flüge aus im großraum athen
mussten tausende in ihren autos
stundenlang ausharren auf den straßen
ging nichts aber der seltene schnee
zauber verursacht nicht nur chaos
sondern auch ungewöhnliche motive
wer design liebt für den sind solche
klassiker so etwas wie die mona lisa ist
der möbel kunst der lounge chair von
charles und ray eames seit 1956 ein
zeitloses objekt der moderne in der
gleichen liga spielt der freischwinger
stuhl von marz darm und masse breuer
bauhaus avantgarde aus den 1920 er
jahren die immer noch modern aussieht
genau wie die panther chairs von verner
panton aus den 60er jahren pop für die
ewigkeit
doch man muss nicht nur bewundernd in
die vergangenheit blicken auch heute
entstehen design-klassiker die ihren
platz in museen finden etwa von
konstantin grcic eine der großen seiner
zunft und aktuell mit einer ausstellung
im berliner haus am waldsee zu sehen
stephan merseburger hat ihn dort
getroffen
konstantin grcic ist ein perfektionist
vielfach preisgekrönt er stellt möbel
und objekte aus die er selbst kreiert
hat und fügt etwas irritierendes hinzu
pandemie maske home office das ist
unsere neue normalität
digits möbel sind futuristisch sein
stuhl tool ein stuhl der gleichzeitig
als tisch benutzt werden kann bekommt
antennen
die schätzung wird mit smartphone und
tablet halterungen ausgestattet
influenza paradies oder zahnarzt hölle
er spielt mit den objekten stellt dinge
auf den kopf und nimmt sie nun als neue
normalität
wie kann ein gegenstand ein objekt durch
öffnen eingriff kann sich anders sein
und etwas irritieren aber
dann im nächsten moment auch tatsächlich
teil unserer wirklichkeit sein es gibt
das schon seit vielen vielen jahren es
gibt unzählige beispiele dafür zum
beispiel
feuermelder rauchmelder sprenger systeme
die in jedem raum zu finden sind kameras
das ding an die haben wir uns gewöhnen
konstantin grcic ist einer der
einflussreichsten designer überhaupt
nach schreinerlehre und design studium
eröffnete er 1991 ein büro in münchen
seine entwürfe sind innovativ manche
wurden zu ikonen die leuchte mayday oder
der czerwonn ein stuhl mit betonsockel
sind in die design sammlungen der
wichtigsten museen weltweit zu sehen
das bedeutet auf jeden fall eine gewisse
ehre also man ist
auf diesen auf die nähe großer klassiker
die ich auch natürlich selber bewundere
und studiert habe aber angekommen
bedeutet das nicht weil im grunde geht
es nie darum ins museum zu kommen man im
dürften stuhl damit menschen darauf
sitzen können vor vier jahren ist kitsch
nach berlin gezogen aus privaten gründen
intelligente zukunftsweisende produkte
will er die seinen
seinem bellt er kettet er in der
ausstellung mit einem fahrradschloss an
einen rammschutz bügel klimawandel und
nachhaltigkeit treiben ihn um der stuhl
ist aus recyceltem plastik leicht stabil
und mit 80 euro relativ günstig
gestaltung ist nicht mehr nur ein
gestaltungs thema also im sinne der form
sondern
ist ein thema was sich ableitet aus
daraus echte lösungen zu finden
die die zukunft besser aufstellen
lüttich ist ein nachdenklicher optimist
die zukunft macht ihm keine angst er
begreift sie als gestalterische
herausforderung
das was man heute journal weiter geht's
gleich mit der reportage reihe 37° heute
mit dem titel späte diagnose mit folgen
wir wünschen einen guten abend bis
morgen wieder sehen
[Musik]
guten abend mit den schneefällen in
griechenland und in der türkei geht es
morgen zu ende denn dieser wirbel zieht
ostwärts ab für uns interessant ist das
neue hoch friedrich dass die teams noch
auf abstand hält das wird sich aber zum
donnerstag ändern heute nacht ist es
erstmal ganz ähnlich wie in der
vergangenen nacht meist bedeckt und
nordöstlich der elbe kann es auch ein
bisschen nieselregen geben im süden ist
es dagegen klar oder es bildet sich
wieder dicker nebel und am alpenrand
über schnee unter klarem himmel sinken
die temperaturen bis minus 7 grad sonst
sind es in der südhälfte temperaturen
zwischen minus 1 und minus fünf grad im
norden bleibt es milder mit 5 bis 1 grad
und morgen liegen die höchsttemperaturen
zwischen minus ein grad im dauer grau
und 7 grad in schleswig-holstein aber
auch am alpenrand steigen die werte bis
sechs grad denn dort scheint die sonne
besonders strahlend aber auch sonst
haben sie auf den bergen süddeutschlands
durchaus chancen die sonne zu sehen in
norddeutschland sieht das anders aus da
tut sich die sonne schwer meist bleibt
es bedeckt und hier und da fällt auch
ein bisschen nieselregen dann aber
ändert sich das wetter es kommen
sturmtief heran und zwar in den nächsten
tagen ist wird also von norden kälter
und es fällt doch mal wieder etwas
schnee am donnerstag könnte es etwas
schnee regen in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen geben bei einem starken
bis stürmischen westwind am freitag
erreichen die schneewolken dann auch den
alpenrand der samstag wird sehr windig
und wechselhaft guten abend